[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
stasera vorrei portarvi con me in un
viaggio attraverso le dinamiche della
politica e dell'economia moderna in
particolare vorrei partire dalla
constatazione che nel nostro mondo si
riscontrano tre fondamentali paradossi
una dilagante ingiustizia sociale un
problema di sostenibilità è un sistema
politico che continua a proporre logiche
conflittuali
allora partiamo dalla prima e tentiamo
di delineare il quadro della situazione
un quadro nel quale in ogni nazione del
mondo
il 10 per cento della popolazione
possiede almeno il 50 per cento della
ricchezza di quella nazione e secondo i
dati oxfam in pochi anni a livello
globale sarà l'uno per cento della
popolazione a possedere ben il 50 per
cento della ricchezza globale
tutto questo mentre 902 milioni di
persone sono in condizioni di estrema
povertà mentre 735 milioni di persone
soffrono la fame
e mentre ogni anno 3 milioni e 100 mila
bambini muoiono di fame
citando gandhi la povertà è la peggiore
forma di violenza
come possiamo definirci umani stringerci
attorno a quei principi quei valori di
libertà di democrazia di uguaglianza di
solidarietà se poi ignoriamo le
sofferenze dei nostri vicini di chi ha
avuto la sorte di nascere in una nazione
diversa dalla nostra
e che quindi ha avuto la sua strada il
suo destino segnato da questa casualità
le disuguaglianze si riscontrano poi
anche a livello di effetti a livello di
politica interna quindi delle economie
nazionali infatti povertà e
disuguaglianza significa polarizzazione
dell'economia significa divisione e
crepe all'interno del tessuto sociale
significa che alcune persone guadagnano
più molto di più di una grande parte
della popolazione che invece non ha gli
strumenti necessari per andare a
consumare questo a causa anche a livello
economico
questo potrebbe consistere in un grave
problema per le nostre economie perché
se non ci sono se la grande la maggior
parte della popolazione non ha gli
strumenti per comprare questo significa
che lo sviluppo e il progresso la
produzione non può essere ridistribuita
e quindi la ricchezza tenderà a
diminuire causando problemi non solo
alle fasce più deboli più deboli ma in
prospettiva a tutta la società nel
complesso
passiamo quindi al secondo problema dopo
aver analizzato questo questo primo che
a livello sia internazionale che
nazionale causa problemi
insomma consistente che alimentano anche
quel clima di recessione in cui siamo a
meri immersi secondo problema quindi la
terra secondo i dati sta lavorando a un
ritmo di 1,6 volte quello che potrebbe
sostenere questo cosa significa che nel
futuro troveremo ci troveremo a fare i
conti con questa situazione
una situazione che non può più essere
tollerata dal nostro pianeta
e a tal proposito vi vorrei proporre ad
esempio dell'overshoot day cioè il
giorno in cui la terra termina
il suo budget ecologico facendo un
parallelismo con le nostre famiglie
i padri di famiglia i genitori che
guadagnano e portano a casa lo stipendio
utilizzano quello stipendio spalmandolo
su un mese e possibilmente anche
risparmiando bene il budget ecologico è
quello che noi riceviamo ogni anno della
terra nel 1996
abbiamo esaurito quel budget il 4 di
ottobre
dieci anni dopo quindi dieci anni fa nel
2006 l'abbiamo inserito il 24 agosto e
quest'anno l'abbiamo esaurito l'otto
agosto
immaginatevi una famiglia che esaurisce
il proprio stipendio e le proprie
risorse economiche
il 15 del mese come può portare avanti
come può terminare in condizioni e far
crescere la sua famiglia in modo
sostenibile e sicuro allora questo
problema di sostenibilità dobbiamo
affrontarlo al giorno d'oggi siamo
immersi in un mare
l'umanità è immersa in un mare e non sta
facendo niente sta semplicemente
affondando
abbiamo un bivio di fronte a noi
rimanere nell immobilità affondare
oppure metterci a notare tirare fuori la
testa e non solo arrivare a riva o
arrivare a metà del nostro busto mandare
sulla terraferma a prendere una strada e
percorrerla cambiare la prospettiva sui
problemi che abbiamo nel mondo cambiare
il modo di affrontare e di sviluppare le
nostre politiche sociali ed economiche
in tutte queste analisi che abbiamo
finora proposto c'è poi una componente
che non può essere escluse cioè quella
politica e sociale
in un mondo in cui gli interessi
l'indifferenza è un individualismo
spinto oltre alla venerazione del
profitto non possono
far altro che minare le basi del nostro
stesso sistema un sistema che oggi come
abbiamo visto non tiene in
considerazione
l'elemento che sta alla base sia
metaforica che letterale del nostro
sviluppo il nostro pianeta terra
e allora il compito che abbiamo è quello
di delineare un nuovo mondo un futuro
diverso procedere quindi a due conquiste
fondamentali la prima quello di
organizzare e strutturare un sistema di
valori di verso un sistema di sviluppo
diverso con regole diverse e la seconda
conquista cioè quella di mettere in
pratica azioni che possano garantire
l'effettivo l'effettiva realizzazione di
questo sistema
passiamo quindi al primo tagli dalle
analisi che abbiamo finora presentato
abbiamo degli elementi che ci permettono
di riconoscere nuovi principi per un
mondo diverso
l'etica della giustizia la solidarietà e
il rispetto
certo è che sarebbe utopistico
considerare il comportamento
dell'umanità e in modo così ideale così
teorico però è possibile considerare il
comportamento dell'umanità come tendente
alla tutela dell'interesse generale cioè
della maggioranza
questo dobbiamo fare questa è la strada
percorrere considerare l'interesse
collettivo
ovviamente in un'ottica di equilibrio
internazionale perché altrimenti ricade
remo in quello delle aporie che citavamo
prima c'è una polarizzazione diversa che
va ad alimentare se stessa delle risorse
quindi un mancato equilibrio tra le
parti e insieme a una tutela di un
equilibrio mondiale da un attenzione
anche a livello locale perché le nostre
comunità che devono basarsi sulla
solidarietà sul rispetto e sull'etica
della giustizia dovranno far co
dovranno far fronte anche ai problemi
dello spreco ad esempio oggi sprechiamo
mille 300 milioni di tonnellate di cibo
ogni anno mentre ricordiamocelo quei
dati che avevo citato all'inizio 735
milioni di persone soffrono la fame
come possiamo tollerare tutto questo
dobbiamo agire contro la logica del
tutto e subito consapevoli che anche le
nostre azioni influenzano e vanno a
contribuire le azioni e le direttive che
il nostro mondo segue perché la logica
del tutto e subito
purtroppo ci vela gli occhi non permette
di vedere che anche quando noi facciamo
delle scelte commerciali quelle hanno un
costo non solo in termini economici per
il nostro portafoglio ma anche di
trasporto e quindi dell'ambiente della
produzione nell'andare contro le
dinamiche naturali del nostro pianeta
quindi tutte queste azioni devono essere
volte al riassorbimento di quel
capitalismo di quella povertà e di
quella disuguaglianza che prima abbiamo
citato perché citando martin luther king
dovunque vi sia un'ingiustizia nel mondo
è una minaccia alla giustizia in ogni
altro luogo del mondo
tutto questo però non può abbandonare
quella dimensione internazionale che
abbiamo introdotto e quindi la nostra
azione politica deve essere volta a una
logica unitaria dove solo delle
amministrazioni condivise possono
garantire la tutela della pace e
dell'equilibrio andando ora alle azioni
cosa possiamo fare innanzitutto
riconoscere che noi umanità siamo stati
i protagonisti della storia
noi abbiamo fatto la storia noi abbiamo
ancora il potere di poterla cambiare di
poter dare una svolta al mondo in cui
viviamo e quindi cosa dobbiamo fare
prendere consapevolezza dei problemi
che il nostro mondo presenta dobbiamo
studiare
dobbiamo investire sull'istruzione
dobbiamo guardare a tutte quelle realtà
che sono i giovani che sono il nostro
futuro e agire attraverso grandi
mobilitazioni popolari affinché i
governi riconoscono la necessità di
garantire a tutti stesse possibilità
perché stesse possibilità significa
significano confronto idee innovative
sviluppo progresso condiviso trasversale
a tutte le nazioni e non concentrate in
alcuni luoghi del mondo e quindi sulle
misure economiche bisognerà considerare
quei paesi non ancora sviluppati e i
paesi già sviluppati per i paesi non
sviluppati
bisogna richiamare alla mente l'azione
di un segretario degli stati uniti che
finita la seconda guerra mondiale
il segretario marshall aveva deciso
aveva compreso che l'europa per essere
stabilizzata doveva avere le possibilità
economiche di evolvere questa è l'azione
che bisogna rivolgere ai paesi non
ancora sviluppati mentre a quelli già
sviluppati bisognerà investire su
politiche del lavoro inclusive sul
capitale umano e su politiche fiscali
più eque che badino attenzione alla
redistribuzione del reddito alla
tassazione all'elusione e all'evasione
fiscale
problemi che lacerano la società
alimentano quelle crepe del tessuto
sociale di cui parlavamo prima
arriviamo quindi al momento conclusivo
i problemi sono grandi ma le sfide che
esse ci presentano ci mettono in gioco
ci fanno protagonisti del nostro
presente e quindi come dobbiamo reagire
cosa posso fare io per cambiare il mondo
innanzitutto smetterla di fare finta che
i problemi non esistano iniziare a
prendere consapevolezza di ciò che io
posso fare per influenzare e cambiare
dal mondo questo è quello che io credo
sia il problema di oggi ma anche la sua
soluzione siamo di fronte ad una sfida
globale economica ma è una sfida umana
che dobbiamo avere il coraggio di
affrontare con impegno e dedizione
grazie
[Applauso]